hey you dirty Birds we only have one
more episode till season 2 is done but
there still remains a ton of mystery as
to how the season will end so in this
video we're gonna break down all those
tiny little details and theorize where
this train will be headed my puns are
terrible the episode begins where
episode 7 left off pop running away from
the crowd which has become hypnotized by
the kid statue we still don't know why
some of the people in the town are drawn
to the statue through this sound while
others aren't
in fact this question is brought up in
the episode but no one seems to have an
answer I'm hoping this will be addressed
next episode or I will be very
disappointed just supported pop heads
back to the Emporium gloriam where he
searches for the letters between Dale
Lacey the former Shawshank Prison warden
and Alan Pangborn the former Castle Rock
sheriff it's likely pop saw a
resemblance between the statue and the
drawings of the kid and this started to
realize there's a connection between
these letters and what's happening with
the townspeople he pulls out this letter
which I've deciphered using other clips
later on in the episode and it reads
Alan
there are many faces in the dark but the
eyes are always blank and the gaze is
always ravenous so debate the gaze every
day or be consumed no children of our
kind Alan hostages to fortune don't
stand alone
the most striking word here is ravenous
as we've seen the title of Annie's
father's book the ravening angel another
hint that the angel is referring to the
kid and isblank dark gaze below the
letter is a map of the tunnel system
which I wonder how big this system
really is and if pop comes back next
episode which I'm sure he will I'll get
to that in a bit
will he use it to get back to the others
were then reintroduced to Martha Lacey
Dale Lacey's Widow who sold her home in
Castle Rock shortly after the death of
her husband were likely outside of
Castle Rock here in a retirement home
since the lights are still working and
we know Castle Rock has been cut off
from the outside world unfortunately for
her one of aces men is waiting we know
that once one of the spirits of the
settlers takes over her body they will
have access to her memories and that's
exactly what ace wants perhaps Martha
knows something about what
Dale was doing with the kid the kid he
believes is the angel amedy tasked him
with finding we see now that her vision
has been cured but the only new
information ace gets is that Dale and
Alan Pangborn used to send each other
letters letters which are now in the
possession of pop Merrill if he's gonna
find the whereabouts of the kid who he
finds a missing-persons poster of he'll
need to get his hands on these letters
Poppa Nadya meet up with chance who is
also not affected by the hypnotizing
sound and are saved by Abdi they head
for shelter and pop shop and for a place
which sells a bunch of junk has a pretty
advanced panic room type defense system
it seems pop who we didn't see last
episode has been hard at work preparing
pressure cooker bombs
perhaps a skill he learned while
fighting in the Army and for a place
that's supposed to be pretty damn tough
to get into
Annie Jamal and Evelyn are able to get
in with an axe yes slight nod to the
shining the problem with three new
people joining them on the inside is
that they don't know if one of them
could be an assassin under Asus control
hence their interrogation annie is ruled
out since she tells pop about the
underground tunnels and the tombs
underneath the construction site Evelyn
I have no idea why she's even in this
episode she doesn't provide anything to
the story and just gets shot later
finally we have Jamal who pop is able to
deduce is under aces control since the
hole where his earring used to be is
completely healed up nadia saves pop in
the tussle and we see she's come
prepared with vials of Haldol the drug
which can temporarily suspend ace in the
settlers control over their hosts
Jamal or should I say the sutler in
control of him tells Nadia that tomorrow
at dusk she returns meaning a MIDI
beetles emerged signaling the arrival of
ace and his men the reason they haven't
blown the place apart by now is that pop
has something ace wants and he doesn't
want to jeopardize losing it so he
proposes a deal the letters for their
freedom at the same time nadia takes a
train schedule from the board as
children him Chris and Abdi would time
running away from ace so he couldn't
reach them a giant mile-long train that
takes a half hour before it passes it
would give them enough time to escape
meanwhile Andy interrogate strim all
she's looking for her daughter when she
hears yet again the
voice of her mother remember she hasn't
had her meds for quite some time and
this will likely come into full effect
next episode especially since joy may be
filled with Amity spirit the mere
mention of losing her sister prompts any
to stab Jamal in the eyes with syringes
killing him and any chance they could
use him for information in the commotion
pop steal some Haldol which i think is
the most important part of the episode
in uncovering what might happen next in
his final confrontation with ace pop
suicide vest doesn't go off but we saw
just moments ago that pop takes out its
batteries prior to that we see him
injecting a large amount of Haldol and
we know if your body is filled with
antipsychotics during the weaving
process aka the process by which a
spirit is imbued in your body it won't
work similar to what happened to the
bartender we also know that pop asked
any for a map of the tunnels so he
definitely has something planned and it
likely involves him waking up from the
weaving process and using the tunnels to
gain access to the Marston home or
perhaps to wear a MIDI scoffing is we're
just gonna have to stand by for next
episode to see exactly what his plan is
pop tells a stud he's burned the letters
but ace tells him he doesn't need them
if they can gain control a pop they'll
just use him to fish the memories out of
him once he's turned the others - Evelyn
rest in peace make it over the tracks in
the nick of time while Pop is shot dead
but he'll definitely be back well not
many new revelations in this episode I
think we're gonna be in for a bunch of
surprises next episode where is the kid
and what is his connection to all of
this what will happen to joy and will
the spirit of Amity take over her I'm
excited I hope you are too please make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and leave a
comment about what you thought of the
episode below you can also follow me on
twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much